Hey you didn't pay for that crap maybe it's not
for you pizza papa always gets paid all right
pizza papa relax she's just a kid relax yourself
there dr strange where'd you get this cape from
anyway oh that feels authentic it's not a cape
it's a cloak and i suggest you let go you took
this whole suit from the strange museum didn't you
strange music why don't you take some mustard huh
come on it's not permanent
Welcome back
everyone we have some doctor strange two
deleted scenes we'll break down also some
alternate endings some alternate post credit
scenes so if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
the movie is being released on digital this week
so there'll probably be a couple other deleted
scenes i will do videos for those two as soon
as that comes out this one featuring the big
bruce campbell cameo as pizza papa selling the
pizza balls on the 838 illuminati universe earth
it's part of this larger joke that america
chavez is telling dr strange that every earth
she goes to typically the norm is that food is
free like it's weird that it costs money on your
earth because this is part of the deception of
the illuminati's universe they're trying to make
it seem like this perfect earth like everything
looks like it exists in perfect harmony there
are no problems everything seems wonderful when
really that's not totally the case we find out
there's way more sinister stuff going on with this
version the illuminati the whole idea with the
bruce campbell cameo scene is that yes it is meant
to be like a funny scene and they reference a lot
of sam raimi's specific easter eggs from the evil
dead series and bruce campbell's character ash
but it's also meant to be a bit of a
foreshadowing for what eventually winds
up happening in the film with things going off
the rails with this version of the illuminati
like oh it's not exactly as awesome as you thought
it was maybe food does cost money in this universe
he also accuses dr strange of stealing his cloak
of levitation from the doctor strange museum
meaning that his cloak of levitation in this
universe exists in that museum the whole idea
with this verse the illuminati is that yes they
did wind up killing their doctor strange because
they thought that he was the biggest threat to
the multiverse potentially because he'd actually
used their version of the dark hole to dabble in
dark magic and it started to become polluted the
same way that you saw sinister strange basically
get polluted by the book he was way further along
becoming corrupted than the other versions of
doctor strange like the one in the illuminati
universe didn't seem that bad but that's the whole
thing with the illuminati and it's a bit of a hat
tip to mr fantastic because he's the guy that
thinks like 10 steps ahead and he's a bit of a
fatalist if you think about it in the illuminati
comics like they all make the hard choices
together but he more than anything sounds really
grim when he gives you solutions and potential
outcomes all this gets into the whole secret wars
teaser the idea the incursions the destruction of
alternate universes how they choose to protect
their own universe by allowing other universes
other earths to be destroyed there's that iconic
line from the comics where mr fantastic says
everything dies and is basically in response to
the other illuminati saying we can't possibly kill
another earth just to protect our own and his
response is basically like well everything dies
it's eventually going to happen to everyone we're
just helping it along a little bit quicker and
it's for the greater good in our universe like
they feel that their duty to the people in their
own universe is greater than their duty to the
entire multiverse and that's why the team's name
the illuminati has a very sinister connotation to
it i guess they're all supposed to be a bunch of
heroes coming together all the greatest heroes
on this earth but the things that they do are
super shady but dr strange cast his enchantment on
bruce campbell's pizza papa's and he just winds up
punching himself and it becomes this big easter
egg for ash in the evil dead series like if you
watch the evil dead movies his hand basically
gets possessed and starts attacking him trying
to kill him the second post credit scene is meant
to be like the funny post-credit scene wink at
this moment paying it off and when he looks
at the camera and laughs and says ha ha it's
over also looking at the hand it's meant to be a
reference to a couple different things like yes
it's a reference to dr strange's spell wearing off
finally after hours and hours and hours but also
it's meant to be a very sam raimi specific easter
egg like he references a lot of his own previous
movies in other movies is them referencing his ash
evil dead character with the hand that kept trying
to kill him like haha it's finally over because
they've referenced that in previous movies before
and they keep bringing the ash character back
in this evil dead series like ash versus the
evil dead in the tv series is just the latest
example of that but the really cool alternate
ending here the alternate post-credits scene was
actually originally supposed to feature a version
of deadpool like it's a very fourth wall breaking
kind of scene usually deadpool is known for doing
that like there haven't been a lot of fourth wall
breaks in all of marvel movies if you include
all the fox marvel movies too it's usually just
deadpool although in the she-hulk series she hook
is known to break the fourth wall in her comics so
she might wind up doing that during the she-hulk
episodes too we'll see about that the funny thing
about deadpool now with the kang multiverse war
in the secret wars the incursions lead up is that
the timelines are very confusing mcavoy or stewart
these timelines are so confusing but you may have
seen a bunch of marvel reports in your feeds about
deadpool 3 the past week the big news is that
marvel just finally hired a director officially
for that movie meaning that it is actually
moving forward like they were working on a
version of it before for the past couple of years
so marvel just hired sean levy to direct the film
most of you are familiar with at least some of
his movies he's done a lot of really big stuff
the big connection to ryan reynolds is that he's
actually directed the last two of ryan reynolds
biggest films he directed the free guy movie which
actually had a bunch of marvel easter eggs in it
there's a big moment with captain america shield
at the end of the movie with the chris evans cameo
who actually freaked out about the character using
captain america's shield like he was acknowledging
that he had played a version of captain america
talk about fourth wall breaks very in the tone of
deadpool there have been a lot of jokes about how
they were going to bring deadpool into the mcu how
they would address it like wouldn't it be funny if
deadpool just showed up in the mcu during deadpool
3 as if he'd been here the whole time in the
mcu is it going to have something to do with the
incursions the secret wars teaser in the doctor
strange 2 post credit scene the writers were just
saying that they actually had to work all those
details out before they actually wrote deadpool 3.
these are some of the quotes that they've released
about the different way that marvel does things
under kevin foggy than fox did things with their
deadpool movies because originally there were
things that fox would not let them do because they
were in the middle of a buyout deal like there was
a lot of stuff during deadpool 2 that they had
to get rid of and they actually revealed this
completely separate plot for a totally different
deadpool 3 movie that they would have made had the
deal not gone through and marvel not gotten the
deadpool character back they said that when they
were going to do deadpool 3 at fox and it was just
going to be its own little solo movie they were
actually going to do a road trip as a deadpool and
wolverine crossover movie that's right everybody
wondering if they were ever going to do a deadpool
wolverine team up with hugh jackman's wolverine it
was actually going to happen during that deadpool
3 movie the other cool thing that kevin feige just
announced that you may have seen in your feeds
is that he said they would have an official
announcement about the next saga of movies where
everything is headed and of course he was talking
about the secret war saga time runs out all the
stuff that they teased during doctor strange too
doctor strange you caused an incursion and we're
gonna fix it during in the movie one of the major
running story lines in the background is that
a bunch of different characters recently in the
marvel movies the disney plus series have done
things to the multiverse that have destabilized
the cosmic barrier between universes causing
incursions to start happening your arrival here
confuses and destabilizes reality the larger
the footprint you leave behind the greater the
risk of an incursion interesting to do something
like secret wars or and it's sort of like their
next big infinity saga level arc like this is a
secret wars arc that we're in instead of trying
to assemble the infinity stones into the infinity
gauntlet now the whole idea is that they're
trying to prevent the collapse of all reality
everything in all of existence all dimensions
all universes everything how do you go bigger
than the infinity gauntlet avengers end game well
instead of trying to destroy an entire universe
you try to destroy an entire multiverse so really
the incursions themselves started happening
when the kang variants started messing with
the multiverse but then after that a couple other
things started happening that made things way way
worse for instance spider-man and doctor strange
messing up the spell in spider-man no way home
that destabilized the barrier between alternate
universes even more causing even more incursions
to start happening then during doctor strange too
you have scarlet witch you have america chavez
doctor strange crashing all over the multiverse
alternate dimensions messing with alternate
versions of the characters that makes things even
worse more and more incursions start happening so
they just kind of compound the effect of the
kang multiverse war but they themselves didn't
start what was happening with the incursions
that was really loki and sylvie technically in
kang variants so the illuminati john krasinski's
reed richards aren't wrong to be mad at our doctor
strange for what he's done because he has made
the problem even worse it's just that he's only
the tip of the iceberg really this is all just
scratching the surface though when you talk about
the multiverse secret wars time runs out battle
world bringing characters back from other movie
universes like even the version of patrick stewart
professor x that came back wasn't even meant to
be from the fox marvel universe it was an even
deeper cut to the animated series so like this
is the path to bringing back characters like hugh
jackman's wolverine even if it's another version
of wolverine that's more comic book accurate
wearing that yellow costume or like bringing
back a version of iron man tony stark but instead
it's the source of supreme version of tony stark
from another universe they kind of did a version
of that during avengers infinity war for a brief
second but wound up being a deleted scene i've
done a couple videos on it too it's really cool
but because they are releasing doctor strange 2 on
digital i will do more videos for the other bonus
stuff that they release with it like more deleted
scenes but if you spotted any other big easter
eggs in the deleted scenes or you have any big
questions about the characters or what's happening
with secret wars just write it below in the
comments and i'll be sure to add them to my future
videos i was originally working on a fantastic
four video when this dropped so i'll probably post
that either tomorrow or sometime later this week
everyone click here for my black panther 2 first
look video and click here for all my doctor
strange 2 easter eggs from the entire movie
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!